The President of Micronesia,
group of small Pacific islands
standing up to China
in a scathing 13 page letter.
President David Panelo says
China is preparing to invade Taiwan
It goes on to say, quote,
One of the reasons
that China's political warfare
is successful in so many arenas
is that we are bribed to be complicit
and bribed to be silent.
Selina Wang is OUTFRONT in Beijing.
And Selina.
These are incredibly strong words
from a leader of a small nation.
Right, standing up
to the Chinese juggernaut.
How is China responding
Yeah, Aaron, this was an explosive
letter and China
responded by dismissing
it as smears and accusations.
The foreign ministry said
they've always respected
how Micronesia
chooses its own development.
Now, Micronesia is president
David Panelo.
He also revealed that he had
considered switching
diplomatic recognition to Taipei Now,
penniless term
in office is set to expire in
just a couple of months.
He's been the president since 2019.
And this is not the first time
he's spoken out before.
On China's
growing influence in the region.
And the context of this letter
is increasing fears from regional powers
about exactly that.
Military strategists
see the Pacific Islands location
as this key connector between the U.S.
territory of Juan and Australia.
And both the U.S.
and Australia
are concerned about China's
more assertive
increasingly assertive
and aggressive posture in the South
China Sea
as it's been extending its reach
further west into Pacific waters,
including towards Micronesia.
And meanwhile,
the island nations themselves,
they don't want to be a pawn
in this greater power struggle.
China has become a key
trading partner for their economies.
And as Backstrom major projects
in some of those countries,
including highways
in Papua New Guinea and bridges and Fiji.
It is pretty interesting, though,
like to see that.
Okay, so he's leaving power,
but what does this signal
and the fact that he would call it out
and put it out there
for all these other countries
around the world
who are dealing with the same thing,
maybe that's where the power might be.
There's also growing concern.
I understand, Syleena,
of another lockdown in China
where you currently are today,
but not because of COVID
Well, this time, Erin, it's for the flu.
So the Chinese city of Shehan
has published an emergency response plan
that says if community
spread reaches
an acute
level officials can use lockdowns, school
and business closures.
Now, no surprise,
but this has led to significant backlash
on Chinese social media.
I mean, it's only been a few months
since China dropped
zero COVID and Shiyan,
which is a city of around
13 million people.
It went through a brutal lockdown
back in 20, 21.
But it is important to mention
that this emergency plan, it's
not unusual for local governments
to lay out
plans like this to handle flu strains.
And plans like this
have been made before,
even before the COVID pandemic.
But those fears on social media,
they really reflect
the trauma that so many went through
during years of restrictions.
And it's a reminder
that they could lose their freedoms again
in the name of health and safety Erin.